Speaker 1: And unfortunately, we have even more.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE News. This one actually
quite serious. While Marjorie Taylor GREENE
probably stands no chance of becoming speaker
of the House of Representatives, and even though
she no longer has any committee assignments,
she actually has put forth legislation
right now. And this is legislation
that would ban gender affirming care for
LGBTQ youth here in the United States.
Let me read this. This is from LGBTQ nation.
Green has introduced a bill that would make
providing gender affirming care for transgender
minors a Class C felony. It would ban federal
funds, including Medicaid funds, from being
used for gender affirming care for transgender
people. Ban medical schools from teaching about
gender affirming care. Stop health care plans
under the Affordable Care Act, from funding
gender affirming care and ban anyone found to have
performed gender affirming care from immigrating
to the United States. Green's bill lists a number
of procedures that aren't performed on minors,
including castration, vasectomy, any plastic
surgery that feminize his or masculine eyes as the
facial features and, quote, any placement of fat
or artificial implants in the gluteal region.
But implants. Because Marjorie Taylor
GREENE somehow thinks that we're
we're out there getting our kids but implants and
of course to make it seem like she's not a bigot.
She's not putting any of the criminality
on the transgender folks. Oh, God, no,
no. Just the doctors. And if you do any of the
things she's listed in the bill, you face 10 to
15 years in a federal prison. I'm sorry. Minimum
of ten years. Maximum of 25, not 15. So sorry.
This is what they want. This is what they're
trying to do. And again, this wasn't just
some proposal she's put forward. It's an actual
piece of legislation that she has introduced in
the House. The House that, of course, is not
going to take up this legislation right now.
Next year if Republicans win? Who knows? We've
already seen, by the way, some of the things that
she has proposed in this national legislation
happen at the state level. My governor,
Ron DeSantis, this week came out and said, no
more Medicaid funds for gender affirming care.
This is what they want to do. And Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is laying the framework for how they will
do it as soon as they get power. Listen, we
got to take another quick break again. I am
Theron Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in
for David Pakman. And we'll be right back.